estamos en el museo metropolitano de
arte viendo la obra titulada vista del
monte julio northampton massachusetts
después de la tormenta de estomas code a
la cual también se le conoce
coloquialmente como oxbow o podemos
decir lago en herradura esta es una obra
de la escuela de pintura del río hudson
de hamás col a quien se le acredita como
el fundador de la pintura del paisaje
americano la pintura del paisaje se
clasificó de manera temprana por los
académicos europeos y la pintura se
clasificó de manera temprana en la
sociedad estadounidense en cuanto a los
estadounidenses que hicieron trabajar
sus pinturas ellos no querían las
grandes escenas mitológicas estaban
interesados en retratos o paisajes o
vistas como esta
esta es una vista de una escena muy
conocida inusual y natural un lugar en
donde amplio connecticut dobla hacia
atrás en sí mismo es una pintura
bastante grande debe medir cerca de un
metro 50 o un metro ochenta de largo
metro 50 de ancho y esto habla de la
importancia que tomas col quiere dar a
la pintura del paisaje ya que este
género pictórico es un poco
menospreciado pero aquí no sólo tenemos
un tamaño grande además coll inclusive
en esta vista intentaba decir más con el
paisaje cuando pensamos en ser más cool
pensamos en el curso del imperio o en el
viaje de la vida juventud y vemos que en
estos momentos intentaba usar el paisaje
para decir algo más grande y eso algo
más grande también está oculto aquí
esto es realmente ambicioso y no solo es
sobre el paisaje es sobre transformación
es sobre el tiempo es sobre cierto tipo
de metamorfosis también es sobre eeuu y
sobre lo cual se iba a convertir es por
ello que en el lado izquierdo podemos
ver un paisaje devastado por la tormenta
podemos ver un árbol roto podemos ver a
la lluvia que se vierte con fuerza
pájaros que vuelan de manera frenética
cruzando el cielo y también podemos ver
un poco de luz de trueno en el extremo
del lado izquierdo así que tenemos lo
que los historiadores de arte y los
críticos de arte del momento se referían
como lo sublime es decir una imagen de
la naturaleza que salvaje y violenta y
aterradora e impresionante este bosque
virgen y esta tierra intocable que vemos
es un contraste rígido con el ambiente
de construcción de la antigua europa y
es aquí donde tenemos la promesa del
nuevo dt en americano en cambio esto es
tan diferente a lo que nos entrega col
del lado derecho en donde tenemos una
viento norteamericano en un paisaje
virgen transformándolo en una tierra de
cultivo en una tierra en donde pueda
pastar su ganadería en un lugar donde
construir sus casas y así la tormenta
está pasando el suelo empieza a salir y
nos queda una sensación de que esta
tierra de asentamiento es algo que está
ordenado por dios algo que está aprobado
por dios y esto está ligado con la
noción estadounidense de la
manifestación de un destino los
estadounidenses estaban destinados a
dominar esta tierra este paisaje que era
para ellos y en efecto al menos un
historiador del arte estuvo observando
la colina en el centro de la pintura y
leyó aquellas letras en hebreo y cuando
las observó desde arriba y las leyó al
revés desde el punto de vista que tiene
dios entonces el ello del hebreo las
palabras shaddai que significan
omnipotente lo cual se refiere a dios
así se consuma la idea de qué es
era un plan de dios y que dios bendice
américa ahora en términos históricos
aquí tenemos la transición entre lo
sublime y lo pastoral lo pastoral es una
idea pacífica del paisaje del hombre
habitando este paisaje con una sensación
de tranquilidad y de paz y esto podemos
observarlo en estas viñetas anecdóticas
que nos entrega con si miras a la
esquina inferior derecha de la pintura
podrás observar una barca que ha sido
cuidadosamente pintada y también puedes
ver algunas personas que van dejando
este lado de la pintura y personas que
están cruzando en el camino que está
sobre las otras y puedes ver el camino
que va hacia la tierra de cultivo y los
lugares donde las ovejas están pastando
y nuestros ojos pueden viajar de arriba
a abajo
a través de las chimeneas de las pocas
casas que están pintadas por aquí y por
allá así nuestros ojos pueden pasar por
el valle en donde el sol brilla entre
las dos colinas y puedes ver arriba cómo
brillan las nubes y cómo cae el
atardecer y todo esto nos da la
sensación de promesa aquí hay algo
especialmente maravilloso
y pienso que va más allá del
entretenimiento y que representa la
particularidad de la naturaleza también
puedes ver del lado izquierdo un musgo
que está creciendo en la corteza de este
árbol maldito se puede divisar un pájaro
en estos arcos malditos pero tal vez lo
más entretenido sea el fondo central del
cuadro allí está el artista mismo
volteando hacia nosotros y al lado de él
colina arriba están sus pertenencias una
sombrilla que lo refugiar a también hay
una silla hay una carpeta y esta silla
también es una cruz por esto podemos
entender no solo el paso del tiempo
también la transición entre lo virgen y
el paraíso que está construyendo el
hombre todo esto lo podemos entender en
un contexto cristiano si te fijas bien
en su carpeta ésta tiene su nombre y
justo ahí nos da la firma de la pintura
de hecho también podemos ver esta
carpeta como un sepulcro para el artista
y es por eso que tenemos la sensación
del paso del tiempo
pero ahora quiero regresar una palabra
que usamos a su momento la palabra clave
es entretenimiento porque aquí estamos
en la primera mitad del siglo 19 y con
esto tenemos una clase media como
audiencia y un nuevo aumento en la clase
comerciante de donde goals saca sus
patrones para pintarlos por ello aquí
tenemos esta necesidad de entretener a
exhibir estas pinturas y hacerlas
divertidas de las personas que la
admiren esto no es complicado no es
mitología es el día a día de la sociedad
americana lo que hace que en verdad te
enamores de la obra